little things that make me feel like
that person was thinking about me and
only me in that moment I don't disagree
I need to show it women in the next
episode maybe you could tell he was high
out of his mind when he bought it it was
during that time oh yeah and that's why
I couldn't tell you when I was telling
the story about the ring the last time I
I it sounded like maybe I wasn't
appreciative of it
and the reason that I couldn't fully
appreciate it at that time but I
couldn't tell you guys is because he was
acting very erratic and very suspicious
and I couldn't like connect the dots at
that time so when he out of nowhere says
here's the ring it made me feel like
wait like what are you trying to put a
salvan because like you know our our if
it felt like he was just trying to put
out a tiny fire it wasn't really like
here's a ring oh god I know I know I
know I know I know I know but but it's a
beautiful ring it's a [ __ ] ring and I
was so hot [ __ ] it's like I don't
know what it was expensive but that was
ugly I don't know what the [ __ ] was
going on with my mind but I was in a and
I was lost I was in a state of man mania
that was my first Pandy so my first pair
the reason I'm so chill about all of
this is because I already had my Pandi
last year for us for four months oh if
my Pandi was rough that was a rough time
I mean remember when it was the roughest
was you guys were all in the room dude
we're no one remember you gotta have we
talked about that this was crazy so we
did a podcast a live show a live
broadcast and afterwards she just looked
at me and you guys were both in the room
and she said I'm not in love with you
anymore
I'm done with that damn selfish me
Georgia like looked at each other my
heart just iced my heart just dropped
and she left the room and I just thought
oh life is over it's different
something's changed
I [ __ ] up I'm a piece of [ __ ] but you
were too high to consider those things I
mean that's the whole [ __ ] [ __ ] it's
you know the reason why I got sober as
listen I was out for what three months
getting a smoking pot right but the
reasons why I got sober as quickly as I
did right is the fact that there were
three or four things that were was
happening that to me felt like too great
of a loss you know my relationship with
kalila was number one you could tell
that it was in the fringe of of just it
was gonna be you know and I did I
couldn't that was just too difficult for
me to live through and number two I mean
those other ones were health and my
state of mind and then maybe may career
was fourth or fifth on the list but that
one day when that was the big that was a
huge wake-up call for me because you
guys were both in the room and we looked
at each other and we we all felt like oh
it's over you know and I remember
feeling like like I never usually lied
to myself in that way but I could feel
the lie reverberating in my whole body
because I was lying when I said that I
could like I just wanted to shake you so
badly because I thought that yeah I
remembered you saying that if I relapse
or if I'm not in a good state leave me
let me hit a bottom so I thought that I
was aiding in that way where if I just
lied through my teeth and tell and you
know just be strong and said okay you
know I am not in love with you I don't
know who you are anymore I'm packing and
I'm leaving I thought that maybe that
would shake you but it kind of like you
know mm-hmm
I was so I mean I also remember
Gilbert's look at me and there was like
a there was a there was a sense of like
he was given without you didn't say
anything you looked at me like would
would chamber lies sad eyes but it was
sad but it was like what would you do
kind of buys but who stayed there the
whole night until you guys finish
talking you did I did I know and you're
the adhesive you were an adhesive that
night you were you know you know what
you are
you know Taco Bell know what you know
that yes and the refight Breen and then
they put the soft over around it what
they call that the soft shell yeah the
soft shell one you're that you're the
refight brain I'll take that however I
told you I could tell George look so
uncomfortable so I told him you can go
home I'll wait here like what's the best
thing to do with this moment that I had
no I had no yeah like everybody was in
different like head spaces what were you
that was just trying to what were you
thinking literally like what trying to
think think of what's the best thing to
do with but like you and kalila were in
such different headspace as it was like
which which side do I like help with to
like bring everybody together and I had
no idea it was after it was right after
the final show in the in the old
apartment yes when this happened kalila
found out our guest put all the pieces
together or bobby emitted it literally
right before they walked into the room
so if he were at the live show at the
old house Bobby kalila Smita faith I
knew something was wrong with kalila
because she was not smiling for real but
Bobby got a lot of glitter on my eyes to
try to mask my puffy eye so I put like
the you know in you for a euphoria that
they put a glitter that's what I did
those are like oh maybe it won't be so
obvious could my eyes were so puffy I
had just cried for like a whole hour
before right before that um that was a
show great show though
how the [ __ ] you did that knowing all
this bullets that was a great show huh
yeah well I'm a professional I would say
that was really good that was impressive
but let's do just knowing like
afterwards yeah okay George yeah that
just that that hit hard huh so update
the update is I have what over a hundred
and ten days